Going to rain fair
but have no idea what to wear.
I got you, baby.
You wanna start with a base dress.
It can be any color you want.
Or you can use a top and a skirt.
It doesn't matter.
I'm gonna use this purple dress
because I have things that go with it.
Then you wanna choose a corset or a bodice.
It doesn't matter what kind,
but it definitely does tie the outfit together.
I'm going with this one.
Then you wanna add another skirt for a layer.
And let's just go ahead and add another skirt
while we're at it.
And then hike it up so you can see those layers.
Now we need something on our head.
Flower crowns are always a good go to for Rinfair,
but I don't really like it with this outfit,
so I'm going to use something else instead.
I'm gonna use this witch hat
that my friend crocheted me for my birthday.
Then I'm gonna add my potion bottle on for accessories.
And there we go.
That's the completed Rinfair outfit.
I hope you guys like it.